hi I'm Eric Porter I'm a professional
mountain biker and I'm gonna teach you
how to get started with mountain biking
I love mountain biking cuz it's a great
way to get away from everything get out
into the woods ride your bike challenge
yourself and have a great time you'll
want to check out your bike before you
ride you want to make sure you have
enough tire pressure
make sure your chain is lubed and not
squeaky and then go through the gears
and make sure it's shifting properly
after ride it's a good idea to look over
your bike as well make sure it's
generally in good working order before
you hang it up for the day if you get in
over your head with maintenance or don't
know what you're doing
feel free to take it into your local
bike shop and they'll be more than happy
to help you out and teach you a little
bit more about it pumptrack is a great
way to improve your mountain bike skills
when you're not on the trail and what
that is is usually a fairly small track
that's rollers and berms and you're
gonna basically push your bike through
the bottoms of these rollers and pull
them up over the top and you're working
those rollers to gain speed
the reason pumping is so important is
that you can transfer that onto a trail
pump through dips in the trail and carry
more speed which means less pedaling the
best way to find a place to ride your
mountain bike is on MTB project comm and
that's going to send you straight to all
of the best riding places based on your
current location that has the full trail
rating system has pictures from most
trails a profile that shows how much
you're climbing and descending and a
nice map that is downloaded on your
phone as well there's a few things to
talk about regarding trail etiquette
always yield to the uphill rider just
pull over and let them on by they're
climbing and they're working hard you
want to be respectful of the trail you
don't want to be skidding all over the
place or cutting corners or anything
like that stay on the trail keep a
single track the trails don't build
themselves check out your local
volunteer Trail days and go help now
that you know a little bit about trail
etiquette how to find trails and how to
take care of your bike go out there and
have some fun
[Music]